ce nouveau chiffre maintenant qui fait
froid dans le dos d'après l'unicef plus
de la moitié des enfants ukrainiens ont
dû quitter leur maison depuis le début
de la guerre il y à un mois quatre
millions trois cent mille enfants
déplacés à cause de cette guerre parmi
eux près de deux millions d'enfants ont
quitté l'ukraine les autres ont été
déplacées à l'intérieur du pays la
pologne reste en première ligne pour
accueillir les réfugiés ukrainien depuis
le début de la guerre il y à un mois
plus de 2 millions d'ukrainiens et ont
trouvé refuge notre envoyé spécial
pauline godard étape une échelle à la
frontière entre l'ukraine et la pologne
regardez
juste derrière moi cet ancien centre
commercial qui a été transformé en
centre d'accueil et d'hébergement pour
les réfugiés environ 5000 réfugiés
peuvent passer la nuit ici en ce moment
ils sont un peu plus d'un millier nous
ont confié des bénévoles à l'intérieur
différentes salles ont été aménagées en
dortoir il ya surtout des femmes et des
enfants nous avons été autorisés à
rentrer à l'intérieur mais de seulement
quelques mètres pour pouvoir vous
décrire tout ça on trouve aussi de quoi
se vêtir se restaurer se soigner chaque
réfugié est enregistrée il peut ensuite
se rendre dans un stand devant ce stand
le drapeau du pays qui peut les
accueillir il ya le danemark
l'angleterre l'espagne l'allemagne ou
encore la pologne une fois leur choix
faits et quand des places sont
disponibles
ils prennent un bus direction la gare
d'objets mais shell ils prendront
ensuite un train pour être conduits dans
une plus grande ville polonaise et de là
ils pourront rejoindre le pays de leur
choix